welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar basket trials
biomarker driven drug development it is
presented by Shivani Kumar a professor
of medicine in oncology and of radiology
in the molecular imaging program the
director of phase 1 clinical research
and director of the translational
oncology program at Stanford University
my name is Judy O'Rourke and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before I begin I would like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Kumar I will
now turn the presentation over to her
thank you Judy for the introduction as
mentioned I'll be talking about the so
called basket trials discussing the
underlying rationale design and
challenges in conducting such trials so
as you are aware there was a great
paradigm shift in oncology with the
development of the molecular targeted
agents the rationale for developing
these agents is that the target is
important for disease initiation or
progression the age
that you're developing modulates that
target and that this modulation is
associated with the desired anti-tumor
effect in the preclinical models this
whole underlying scientific hypothesis
was born out with the dramatic responses
that were seen when VCR Abel was
targeted in patients with CML the
authors concluded that our results
demonstrate the potential for the
development of anti-cancer drugs based
on the specific molecular abnormality
present in human cancer and so on this
opened up a whole field of trying to
identify genomic markers and genomic
targets that can be then exploited as
potentially therapeutic targets for the
treatment of cancer so if we try to
study cancer and look at somatic
mutations over 350 of the approximately
22,000 protein coding genes in the human
genome have been reported to show
recurrent somatic mutations in cancer
and so if we study these and try to
understand which one of them are the
true drivers of the cancer then those
could potentially be therapeutic targets
with the technological advances and the
dramatic decrease in the cost of
sequencing and our ability to perform
the sequencing in a clinically relevant
time frame the number of tumor samples
that are being sampled and sequenced has
grown exponentially the cost for
instance for doing the human genome was
approximately three billion which was a
massive international effort currently
you can get a targeted sequencing panel
done for a couple of thousand dollars
what that has done is there's been an
explosion of information about the
genomics of cancer so cosmic is a
catalog of somatic mutations in cancer
that was launched in 2004 and detailed
information on four cancer genes by 2014
it became one of the largest and most
comprehensive resource and had
information in over 1 million tumor
samples with over 2 million coding point
mutations listed in the database so when
you look at all of that information what
that has done in the clinical oncology
realm is that we have gone from talking
about just pure histology driven
classification of cancer to now adding
on a layer of the genomic driver
mutations and this is especially true in
the case of lung cancer aware for the
non-small cell lung cancer we should
talk about squamous cell and no
carcinoma and large cell
non small cell lung cancers but now we
are also adding on the layer and talking
about EGFR positive out raus and
additional genomic markers this is an
example of a marijuana when it was
developed which remember a flip target's
be roughly 600 a mutations it was
developed initially for melanoma and in
the initial phase one study in the pre
selected enriched patient population
that had melanoma that was b-raf a 600
mutation positive very high response
rates were seen in that trial and this
drug was rapidly developed in a proof
for this indication this also brought
home the point that it shifted the
paradigm for phase one trials from going
from an unselected all-comers solid
tumor population to a population that
actually carried the marker of interest
and the concept of patient enrichment so
in the traditional drug development
paradigm we used to talk about
developing agents for a given tumor type
a given histologic type and talked about
treatment where a particular new therapy
would fit into the treatment paradigm
from there we shifted to talking about a
biomarker subset of a given tumor type
for instance her2 positive breast cancer
or her2 positive gastric cancer or
vemurafenib like I showed in this
example for the be roughly 600 e
mutation positive melanoma but then the
question became that B Rafi 600 e
mutations are not only observed in
melanoma
however they are seen maybe with lower
frequency bit but in other tumor types
so what is the most efficient in best
way to evaluate the maratha nib in the
rest of the tumor types and one of the
trial designs that emerged as the one
that was eventually used are the so
called basket trials what these trials
are is that you have genomic abnormality
and drug pair that you want to test in
multiple tumor types that carry that
particular genetic abnormality so
patients are screened and if the tumor
carries the particular action code and
code actionable mutation then the
patients are treated with on study if
they don't have that option about
mutation then they are off study so
brembo raffinate basket trial was
designed and as shown here there what
the way the patients are screen is they
come in the tumors are sampled and if
they carry the be roughly 600 e mutation
and have say lung cancer they are
enrolled onto the lung cancer cohort if
they have cholangiocarcinoma they've
gone to the cholangiocarcinoma cohort
and so on and then there is one cohort
that is quote unquote a basket for all
other solid tumors that carried this
particular mutation what this allows us
that each of the cohorts is
independently powered and you can draw a
conclusion if vemurafenib is active for
that particular tumor type also because
there are so many breads human
types the basket the cohort that
actually takes all the solid tumors
would allow you to endure all patients
who regimen types and evaluate this
therapy in those humorous as shown here
there's a variation in the level of
activity observed especially in the
right lower panel where there are
multiple tumor types there are some that
respond and some don't
the interestingly one of the rare
disease are a dime Chester disease which
has a 50% incidence of having be roughly
600 in mutation there was a high
response rate seen in this rare
indication for a shift now to a target
that was recently validated and a drug a
proof against this indication which was
also which also went through a basket
trial to show its activity and then I
like to compare the two the Bema Rathnam
and this particular trial you see what
were the differences so tropomyosin
receptor kinase signaling pathway is an
important pathway through which
neurotrophins work that are important
for a promoting sympathetic nervous
system development and they're important
in pain signaling thermoregulation
regulation of movement memory appetite
body weight and proprioception so in one
group the entry our key receptor gets
activated it has an extracellular ligand
binding domain a transmembrane domain
and our tyrosine kinase domain so when
there is like in binding it gets
activated and signals downstream however
if there is a somatic chromosomal
rearrangement with a genetic fusion that
occurs in the 5 prime end there is
constitutive activation of n track and
that results in uncle Genesis
incredibly inclusions have been found in
multiple tumor types and interestingly
some of the rarer tumor types have a
higher incidence of having interacting
fusions such as secretory breast cancer
and infantile fibrosarcoma so in order
to evaluate an agent against tumors that
carry the enteric gene fusions and
because there are so many tumor types
that actually had these tract fusions at
a lower frequency roughly around one to
two percent the best trial design was
felt to be a basket trial for the agent
that was being developed which is
lateral tract in it which is a highly
selective tract inhibitor it has a high
potency against all the three known
tracks and the trial that was instituted
was this phase two basket trial where we
had independent cohorts for lung cancer
thyroid sarcoma colorectal salivary
biliary and primary CNS all tumor types
where there's been reports of n track
few gene fusions and then another cohort
that had all other solid tumors carrying
this encouraging fusion this is one of
my own patients and as shown here this
patient is a non small cell lung cancer
patient that carried the NT rk1 gene
fusion and as compared to baseline after
cycle four you can see there's a
dramatic reduction in the lung mass as
well as liver mass this is a case of an
imprint Hellfire mission with an
infantile fibrosarcoma or two-year-old
female who had combination chemotherapy
with disease progression and was being
considered for leg amputation
however genomic analysis revealed the NT
ArcheAge infusions and the decision was
made to proceed with la retractor lip
treatment after four psycho
there was significant reduction in the
tumor mass and patient was referred for
surgery
surgical reception of the mass revealed
a complete pathologic response and the
amputation was averted and the patient
continues to do well so responses were
seen across tumor types who did not
matter which tumor type in over 17
different histologies were evaluated and
also interestingly it did not matter
which was the gene fusion partner
they've been multiple gene fusion
partners reported for the three and
trucks and but it did not influence the
response rate and the response rate has
been quite durable in majority of the
patients so this data resulted in the
FDA approvingly retract in M for
patients with advanced solid tumors
carrying the NT RK gene fusion this was
a tissue agnostic indication that was
provided by the FDA so if you consider
the basket trials for member alpha wave
and then falero tracked in him that I
mentioned one of the things that sort of
comes across is his tumor histology
important as I mentioned in the
memorandum data and there was a
variation in response rate depending on
the underlying tumor histology even
though all patients did carry the PRF
mutation of interest however in the
lateral tract and hip data that was not
the case so whenever we thinking of
designing a basket trial or developing
an agent against a genomic driver we do
need to consider the preclinical data
that supports evaluation of various
histologies but I think based that
probably the importance of the target is
still disease context dependent and I
think it's importantly initially
evaluated as part of a basket trial
where there are independent cohorts
based on histology and if it turns out
like in the latter tract in the data
that the response rate is not affected
by underlying histology then data can be
pulled together to derive the clinical
outcome one of the other things that
other ways to evaluate are what are
called the so-called umbrella trials and
some people call it the multi drug
basket trials but what these are is
their patients have multiple different
tumors different histologies and they
have different mutations that are
detected and you have a panel of drugs
so if you say if the patient has a
mutation X you pair it up to drug X and
a mutation while you pair it up to drug
Y and patients are treated on study by
this multiple mutation drug pairs a
patient has no actionable mutation then
they are off study multiple umbrella
trials have been conducted and some are
ongoing these are very large efforts
with hundreds of patients paired to
multiple treatments one of the studies
there was an international effort called
the shiver trial initial data was
reported for 741 patients randomized to
targeted treatment versus physician
choice in this the targeted treatment
was a hormone receptor modulators the
pi3 we were trying to target the P I 3 a
KTM 2 a pathway and the Rostov met
pathway there were 11 different targeted
treatments evaluated and data reported
for the initial 195 patients that were
randomly assigned 99 were assigned to
the experimental group and 92 to the
control group the median
progression-free survival was 2.3 months
in the experimental group and two months
in the control group so there was really
no
difference based on all the selection
this raised a lot of questions about is
it worth making all this effort for
genomic selection of targeted treatment
in cases where we know that something is
a true driver mutation or fusion then I
think it's very clear that doing genomic
sequencing and treating that patient
with a targeted agent against that
driver will result in clinical benefit
as shown with the maratha nib and i
retract in him the only caveat as I
mentioned before is that not all drivers
are equal there may be a histology
tissue dependent contacts to it
however the question about the rest of
the ones that are unclear whether
they're either driver or passenger
mutations the jury's still out whether
targeting it would result in clinical
benefit so I wanted to go through some
of the considerations as we think about
designing these molecular profile driven
trials and treatment selection first is
like how do we define national ability
what do we call a quote unquote driver
or something that we want to target with
a targeted agent so usually
actionability is defined as a genetic
aberration or mutation if it is
oncogenic and our different Tillie
express yourself and there is an age in
a drug that putative lis works against
it so you should be able to detect that
mutation or aberration using the panel
that you're using for sequencing and
then have an agent that you think hits
either that target directly or somewhere
downstream of it so like I mentioned we
need to be clear on what we are calling
a driver just having the mutation be
present does not mean that it is truly
driving the chima growth so we need to
make sure that
there is a functional consequence of the
mutation that we are detecting also most
of the patients we are trying to get
samples and we do interventional
radiology guided tumor biopsies which
have small tumor biopsy content like
shown here you have areas where there is
tumor and then areas where there is
normal tissue and supporting stroma so
what should be the tumor content of the
biopsy that needs to be analyzed to
reach a conclusion of having an
actionable mutation from the sequencing
also there is this whole data that has
emerged about chamber heterogeneity so
there is ongoing regional clonal
evolution there's difference between
regions within a given tumor between the
primary and the metastasis and it has
also been shown by gurdlinger at oral
that the number of biopsies that you
analyze from a given tumor there is an
increase in the number of code encode
actionable mutations that you detect
from that sample so what we need to
really understand is that what are we
considering as a representative sample
that then needs to be sequenced and then
that data used to drive the eligibility
as well as the treatment for the patient
and should we be now thinking about
circulating cell-free DNA as another way
where maybe multiple cells are shed so
we may have a better handle on tumor
heterogeneity then the core biopsies
that are currently performed also then
the question is how many of those cells
that we are analyzing need to carry a
mutation of interest before you will be
excited enough to say that there is an
actionable component in the tumor some
people state that majority of the cells
need to carry a given mutation of
interest before it's worth feeding that
patient with a targeted agent and they
did
doing some benefit others feel that if
it is a fraction but maybe it is the
quote unquote stem-cell fraction then
targeting that would be sufficient what
about single versus multiple aberrations
so it depends on what kind of panel
you're using and what you're looking for
but very easily you can imagine that you
will find multiple genetic abnormalities
in a refractory solid tumor this is data
from MD Anderson that showed that the
median time to treatment failure was
better with a targeted agent if there
was one aberration present however there
was no difference in the time to
treatment failure or the response rate
if more than one aberration was present
between a matched targeted therapy or
without matching this is interesting
data but also it highlights the point
that sometimes you find more than one
because you're looking for more than one
also it depends on what match therapy
you're using and then whether the one is
the true driver or not so I think we
need to be careful and analyzing data
such as this because we do need to find
out what the functional consequence of
each of the aberrations is before we say
the presence or absence of an aberration
makes a difference also if we find more
than one aberration that is actionable
by our definition which one should we
target first iterate clinical benefit
and if there is any data for the safety
of a combination regimen I think what is
important is for us to understand before
we design these target these basket
trials is the what is the level of
evidence for defining actionability
I showed you example four whereas
and then I retracted and those are
agents that directly target the genetic
abnormality that we believe are the
drivers there can be ones where you are
not targeting that directly but you're
targeting downstream of it there are
others where there may be compensate or
a pathways that we are as yet unaware of
and then all of this is as good as the
drug of interest that you are studying
so I think as we move forward there is a
lot of excitement in the field where
genomics and there have been major
advances in the field and in clinical
benefit to our patients however as we
develop more therapies we need to be
aware of all these considerations there
needs to be a lot more work on the
functional consequences of various
genetic abnormalities that are being
described and then altering that how
does that change the tumor and how does
it result in anti-tumor activity as well
as what does the normal tissue
vulnerability or of us targeting these
abnormalities so I think it's an
exciting time to be in oncology and
these we are developing a lot more
promising agents and genomics is driving
a large part of it thank you
thank you dr. Kumar for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May 27th 2019 as a final
reminder our speaker will follow up with
any questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we will see you next time goodbye